alors bienvenue à ces démissions
musulmans jusqu'à notre est riche de
près du khan à titre national ici
stéphane parent en compagnie de tous nos
compagnons des ondes
ici à radio canada international ou en
tout cas entre cette semaine ont fait
des rotations on découvre des nouveaux
visages et aussi des visages anciens
pour ne pas dire début visage
je vous rappelle que cette mission elle
dure depuis plusieurs années c'est un
thème canada bonjour tout le monde c'est
vendredi près de nous c'est le plaisir
qui nous anime et on retrouve des bons
amis marie claude simard est avec nous
plongera genre on retrouve un des plus
fins esprits des radio canada bah je me
découvre bonjour tout le monde vous avez
tout de suite senti que c'était vous
tous alors c'est samir bonne affaire est
pour nous commente et puis maryse sais
je vous ai pas décrit comme un des plus
fins les esprits vous êtes très fine
non mais c'est parce que je pensais que
vous fassiez référence à moi lorsque
vous êtes vieux visages
je me suis senti un peu visés mais bon
ça ma bombe a coûté ça commence par la
démission démission c'est qu'aucun
d'entre vous encore une fois on avait
l'idée du sujet dont il va traiter jours
passent et les surprises mais c'est
toujours présents de découvrir votre
surprise est aussi découvrir aux
questions qui peuvent parfois à certains
apparaître très terre à terre mais au
toujours en pleine cible alors ou alors
pour les compliments cette semaine c'est
bien maintenant place à la vidéo la
vidéo 5 images qui vous permet à décoder
découvrir le sujet aujourd'hui vous vous
crier dès que vous sentez qu'on est sur
la piste du sujet aujourd'hui tout le
monde participe pas seulement studio
mais aussi à la régie pensa non c'est
pas ça
cette diversité non ça c'est pas ça on a
maintenant on n'est pas bien on
recherche la vidéo 5 images vidéo 5
images pas du sinus
vidéo cinq images
est ce qu'on a on parlait peut-être que
stéphane pourrait comme mimi sujet ce
serait très très bien
l avez-vous trouvé la régie sinon je
vais être obligé de me mais est ce que
je demandais à ériger nouveau parce que
c'était poste de signal n'était pas
clair en provenance de mars
est ce que vous avez trouvé la vidéo pas
encore alors voici j'anime fabriquer un
véhicule
ah oui oui vous êtes sur la bonne piste
est-ce qu'on est sur une autoroute est
ce qu'on fait de la vitesse vous est
pris de vitesse au et en prix le grand
prix ça a vraiment su ce que vont
recevoir et grand prix quand ils ont
réalisé l'exploit quand il ya une
expédition capables ils sont baissières
plusieurs deux équipes en compétition
présentement pour atteindre ouais mais
tu es une traversée du monde boit des
traversées certainement à quoi du monde
de soccer féminin d'un continent
peut-être qu'un jour ils vont réussir à
traverser en continent grâce à ce
véhicule et les coqs
c'est ben oui je parle cette électrique
mais ça dépend des compagnies qui sont
en train de concevoir sa wii bien non
c'est pas un avis en trottinette
électrique
regardez on a trouvé la vidéo ou pente
of a c'est donc un grand vide as a
service la semaine passée par le tunnel
de qu'il avait tourné la tête il ya
comme un numéro de montréal à toronto
c'est une petite capsule certaines
versions cd langue capsule qui vont
traverser comme ça les tunnels où on
aurait enlevé de l'air je pense qu'ils
voulaient un temps de talent
non il ya dix jours de pipeline n'est as
we déplacement humain j'ai pas pour des
questions environnementales se voit les
bateaux de tout ça alors c'est un
système de transport futuriste imaginée
par hellman tellement l homme masque
initialement witness leurs propriétaires
de derrière stein de l'art moderne se
bat pour la gestion des finances on
reviendra alors il ya plusieurs
compétiteurs là qui s'acquitteront qui
te font ce travail là présentement y en
a eu que j'aime beaucoup c'est un de
ceux dont on parle beaucoup dans le
monde ça s'appelle https je me suis un
acronyme qui veut dire à plus loupé rail
pearl où il perd le procès la boucle y
parle boucle ici on peut dire c'est bien
d'y transporter qu'une technologie
d'accord et puis là il
il leur dernière version c'est une 5
tonnes c'est parti c'est pas comme une
volkswagen ne trouve au wagon une
coccinelle sa mesure 32 mètres de long
la cabine interne 15 mètres de long et
ça transporte et bah c'est ça la
question on va aller vers notre premier
tour de la grosse bourde huile sa route
sur quazar sur pneumatiques sur la
version ok ok mais comment exactement ce
transport le hyper loupe vers le https
lieberman avait déjà tendu par les ss
oui le tue le fameux tube où je sais pas
ça j'en ai entendu comme si le trans
prod transports byron ça c'est nous prod
si nous la production mais moi je
préfère la france oui quand on
transporte quelque chose d'un nombre
pour transporter très jolie oui ça c'est
plus sympathique d'ailleurs ces
canadiens ça dit tout là on va parler
avec un des responsables de transport
dans un instant si vous le permettez le
jus ou le jaune la place où je 20 boules
à perdre trois jeux à travers des
missions sans boulot total à perdre au
premier tour les bulls
alors voici on présente la question à
l'écran pour tout le monde pour ceux qui
ont les couleurs la télévision sur le
web
voici le produit était présentée par la
compagnie pearl ou transporter qu'une
technologie avec une copine une cabine
interne de 15 mètres pourrait
transporter combien de passagers
demandait samir à 20 passagers b
quarante passagers ou ses 81 passagers
quelle est la bonne et vincent giret
pour 40 40 maximum la scène sinon ça va
être comme des sardines
où et comment les aimions marie-claude
20 40 ou 80 81 81 mon dieu parce que ces
deux rangées de 40 comme dans un avion
alors ne vais pas sage et ça je vais
aller avec celui là parce que je me dis
que peut-être qu'on veut offrir une
expérience client très confortable
donc on aura moins de gens mais pour moi
ce serait très exclusif aussi un peu
comme dans concorde selon l'irish du
voyage oad way j'ai cette impression la
réponse on regarde elle s'affiche à
l'instinct l'écran je vais avoir du
monde à vrai dire on connaît pas
vraiment la capacité de cette capsule la
nouvelle capsule qui s'appelle quintero
one mais le site spécialisé qui
s'appelle engadget qui dit gordon oke
salle à peu près la taille d'un wagon de
métro de new york
on peut mettre 80 passagers
confortablement à l'an passé
mais lorsque tout le monde sera sinon ce
sera comme dans le métro il ya déjà ça
n'est pas la vitesse qui y vivent non et
c'est là devant les amis km heure debout
oui dans un avion on peut être de bois
on est à 900 km donc j'ai même dit louis
dionne 1200 km 1
plus rapide que la vieillesse il n'y a
pas de soucis après de vibrations aux
potes de besoin je pense qu'on va avoir
une vidéo dans une instance vous
présenter je veux pas le dire trop fort
mais peut-être voici la vidéo numéro 2
qui j'ai appelé ça https il joue quand
la dernière version ça fait quelques
années qu'on y travaille donc vous allez
voir c'est le bout du train qui présente
en fait l'objet d'essais en france
si mes souvenirs sont bons c'est en
france dont vous allez voir ça la
capsule d'héliport look de la société
achetée à tester à toulouse en france
why should de ça c'est pas les seuls qui
testent leur équipement en ce moment je
viens de vous parler de l'initiative
canadienne après qu'on a admiré le
profil de 7,7 de sa de oui on a amerri
le profil je vais vous montrer le
premier des premiers tests
[Musique]
prendre du temps avec le temps de dire
qu'il fait très beau nevada il fait
soleil sont testés dans sa lettre
160 km 160 et on savait alors là c'est
beaucoup de choses à dire là dessus on
va aller vers notre invité spécial
aujourd'hui qui il est je sais pas si
dans une cabine de transport mais ça
ressemble ces suspects sont à faire
sébastien gendron cofondateur et pdg des
transports bonjour monsieur le patron
alors vous êtes tous en ce moment envie
que l'automobile oui je suis en france
alors vous êtes à toronto et on peut
expliquer les dimensions tentaculaire
que prend votre entreprise au niveau des
succursales là où vous trouver là où
fait des tests donnent une idée vous
n'êtes pas juste des grands laboratoires
vous êtes une vraie compagnie avec des
ambitions très sérieuse avec l'intention
de faire compétition à l'autre géant
https contenu oui effectivement après il
ya en fait cette entreprise développe
cette thèse
j aujourd'hui et dont trois principales
de aux états unis dont vous vous levez
vous mais de montrer les vidéos et
transports du canada et donc on reste
encore aujourd'hui une petite entreprise
mais avec des premiers investissements
européens notamment italien et bientôt
français et canadien donc on devrait
clôturer notre prochaine levée de fonds
cet été là avec notamment voilà des
investisseurs français canadiens et donc
du coup on a et on a donc on développe
cette nouvelle technologie entre
l'europe et le canada
cannell alors jusqu'à maintenant ce que
j'ai trouvé impressionnant c'est votre
présence sur le web les vidéos les
multiples entrevues que vous accordez
aux médias vous êtes vous avez une
approche qui est très ouverte comparé à
d'autres compétiteurs à ses très polis
et c'est très bien policé je peux
bien peu à comprendre aujourd'hui alors
là on voit l'intérieur potentiellement
de ce que ça pourrait être voyagé avec
transpole
c'est impressionnant mais vous en est où
au plan technique
alors aujourd'hui on en est encore au
début on est on commence à passer des
phases de tests en laboratoire aux
essais en fait à échelle une on a obtenu
les permis de construire pour lancer la
construction d'un centre d'essai au sud
quant au sud de paris nord de limoges
donc centre centre de la centre de la
france donc on commence les travaux cet
été et pour que justement commencé à
valider l'ensemble de ces de ces
sous-ensembles ensuite par rapport au
développement en fait on vise une une
certification et une commercialisation à
l'horizon 2025
donc on a voilà on a à peu près 50
développement devant nous la bonne
nouvelle c'est que les différents
gouvernements commença à se comment on
va dire ceux ci résident est très
fortement la technologie on a on
travaille aujourd'hui avec l'union
européenne sur le cadre réglementaire
on a déjà eu plusieurs réunions de
travail en a encore une la mi juillet à
bruxelles
transports canada a lancé une étude de
faisabilité technique pour évaluer le
niveau de maturité de la technologie et
les etats unis ont lancé un comité
technique pour créer aussi et définir ce
cadre réglementaire donc tout le monde
voilà développe la technologie petit à
petit pour arriver à une maturité en
fait technologique et une
commercialisation autour de 2025
donc on peut potentiellement avoir les
premières lignes avant 2030 et au canada
aujourd'hui la province avec laquelle on
est le plus avancé
c'est en alberta on travaille
aujourd'hui à avoir une ligne en fait
entre calgary edmonton et la deuxième
ligne ensuite dans un deuxième temps
serait
toronto montréal juste pour l'anecdote
le gouvernement fédéral nous avait dit
commencé déjà avec une seule province
toronto que ontario québec c'est pas
forcément tous les jours évident essayez
avec les choses de simples d'abord et
puis ensuite l'ontario et le québec
pourront embarquer dans cette aventure
qu'elle sage décision et on se bouscule
ici pour vous poser des questions on
fait le tour on y va oui moi je me
demandais est-ce que ce projet là vous
l'avez déjà vous l'aviez déjà en tête
avant d'arriver au canada
alors je suis arrivé au canada en 2010
pour travailler pour bombardier et moi
personnellement je suis pas un très bon
employé j'ai un peu du mal avec les
grosses entreprises donc je peux
réfléchissait déjà à démarrer ma propre
société et travaillant dans les
transports au canada en venant d'europe
en plus je m'étais dit tiens ça peut
être intéressant d'avoir une compagnie
aérienne low cost ce qu'on n'a pas
vraiment de compagnies low cost au
canada et puis les choses ont fait que
voilà on regardait aussi tout ce qui
était transport par tube et quand elon
musk a commencé à présenter au grand
public ce concept là en fait c'était un
petit peu la fenêtre de tir pour pour
démarrer la société et là je me suis
associé avec un chercheur de
l'université de toronto qui s'appelle
ryan johansen
c'est notre notre savons chez transpole
qui en charge un petit peu toute
l'architecturé du système et aujourd'hui
voilà notre avantage clairement
concurrentiel c'est la propriété
intellectuelle on a des brevets qui
vraiment nous donne un avantage
par rapport à la concurrence et en gros
ça se résume à garantir un business qui
est meilleur que meilleur que ce que
d'autres sociétés peuvent proposer
marie-claude elle veut nous expliquer
c'est quoi laisser ce à quoi les
avantages de se déplacer par comme ça
plutôt que par train ou par avion
alors quand on quand on s'est lancé dans
cette aventure on s'est dit il faut que
ce soit meilleur que ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui
sinon vous avez raison autant utiliser
la voiture le train l'avion ou même le
bateau donc vous avez ça permet la
vitesse déjà que ce soit enfin c'est
plus rapide c'est quand même intéressant
de pouvoir faire demain toronto montréal
en 45 minutes ensuite il faut que ce
soit moins cher que ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui donc un prix du ticket
aujourd'hui toronto-montréal aller
simple on réfléchit on vise des tickets
entre 60 et 80 dollars
aller simple il faut que ce soit
respectueux de l'environnement donc
céder c'est un système qui est 100%
électrique et qui peut remplacer on va
dire 70% des vols entre toronto et
montréal
quand je dis ça c'est pas pouvoir
concurrencer air canada air canada
demain peut être un client de transport
c'est-à-dire qu'au lieu d'acheter des
avions ils peuvent acheter des pod et
opérer des pod quelque chose de plus
propre que les avions est là dès le
dernier facteur en fait des très
importants aussi des plus faciles
d'utilisation
donc c'est de fournir la fréquence du
métro avec la vitesse de l'avion est à
dire que vous avez pu le stress de
manque et votre avion de de dire mme
ainsi une tempête de neige les avions
pas décoller où je vais te retard parce
qu'il faut des givrés l'avion et c est
de pouvoir arriver à la station et
prendre le prochain véhicule qui va sur
sur toronto
et si vous manquez votre véhicule vous
savez qu'il y en a un qui suivent comme
le métro en fait vous avez le véhicule
d'après qui par deux minutes après sur
sur toronto
donc c'est vraiment fait ce qu'on a on a
vu avec les transports de à la demande
comme hubert et lift la prochaine
génération c'est d'appliquer en fait ce
transport à la demande pour le transport
de masse donc
les les trains et les 1 l'équivalent du
train et de l'avion mais mais à la
demande et un gros avantage d'être dans
le tube surtout au canada c'est qu'on
est protégé des éléments extérieurs
oui vous avez pu vous embêter de la
neige de la pluie
voilà des conditions climatiques qui
sont qui peuvent être vraiment
contraignante
vous n'êtes même pas quitter là vous
avez même pas quitter la gare vous avez
déjà un client savait il veut monter
dans le tube même si gendron pour la
construction des tubes
est-ce que vous avez parlé
d'environnement est ce que c'est quoi
les enjeux de l'environnement et est ce
que on construisons ses tubes
est-ce que vous n'aurez pas de problème
avec les communautés que vous allez
traverser est ce que ces conflits c'est
sur terre comment ça va se passer
alors il ya deux aspects il ya le
premier c'est clairement de remplacer un
certain d'avion et un certain nombre de
camions des routes aujourd'hui un
système comme ça peut remplacer deux
mille camions par jour sur l'a4 sont
donc ces camps mais aujourd'hui il ya
dix mille camions par jour sur la 401
donc ce système là pour en enlever 2000
voilà donc ça a un impact de directement
sur réduire la congestion réduire le
niveau d' accident et c'est déjà un
point de vue on va dire système sécurité
et environnement c'est le premier impact
que ça à voir ensuite le
l'infrastructure elle-même tout dépend
de la géographie de la ligne si vous
avez les rocheuses a traversé entre
calgary et vancouver c'est sûr là il
faut creuser des tunnels
si vous êtes entre calgary et edmonton
c'est pour ça que c'est une ligne assez
idéal pour nous placer ces prix là voilà
c'est plat il ya peu de densité
ils ont l'habitude de construire des
pipelines en plus donc c'est quelque
chose qu'ils connaissent et savent un
peu suivre l'autoroute mais en fait
c'est ça que c'est intéressant pour
l'alberta
dès qu'il ya aussi des synergies avec
l'industrie pétrolière
donc au lieu de transporter du pétrole
on transporte des personnes mais on
utilise des technologies donc on peut
reconquérir en fait d d on va dire des
employés des sociétés pétrolières et
diversifier l'économie c'est là où c'est
intéressant pour cette province ensuite
plaint pas
ce qui a déjà été fait avec des
compagnies en particulier
alors oui oui il ya déjà bon on
travaille avec on a travaillé avec
l'ancien gouvernement de riccione glee
et puis là on fera que le cabinet jason
kenny l'ancien gouvernement nous avait
déjà donné 10 km de terrain entre
calgary et edmonton est aujourd'hui en
fait on a des investisseurs qui sont
prêts à construire là les premiers 10 km
à la condition faite du gol qui est un
support du gouvernement c'est à dire que
si la technologie marche
ils veulent avoir l'autorisation de
pouvoir construire la ligne entière donc
on demande pas d'argent on est prêt à
financer les dix premiers kilomètres
mais la contrepartie c'est d'avoir les
autorisations de construire la ligne
complète et est ce que je trouve plutôt
gagnant gagnant comme comme approche
crée des emplois
investir dans la province
si ça marche pas on démonte tout mais si
ça marche ok on veut avoir le droit
pouvoir construire la ligne personne
veut investir des centaines de millions
comme ça à perdre quand vous disiez
plutôt qu'on pouvait remplacer grâce à
ses 1 à ce tube 2000 camions le long de
la 401 qui au québec devient l'autoroute
numéro 20 c'est un corridor très
achalandé et figari qui passent par là
il ya des certains pipeline qui passe
par là et beaucoup ce qui passe par là
moi j'habite par là et je vais vraiment
très proche du corridor où vous voulez
nous envahir
je vous ai invité à l'émission tout en
disant que je pouvais être un jour me
trouver dans votre position écouter ça
va faire du bruit quand ça va rouler
comme ça d'un kilomètre dans le tube
en fait non bon il ya quelques défis
technologiques et quelques avantages et
un désavantage en fait c'est que le
bruit ne se propage pas dans le vide et
en fait on est dans un environnement à
faible pression c'est pas le vide
complet mais alors ça c'est les mesures
que l'on va fait notamment que l'on va
faire notamment sur le site rodez c'est
ici en france mais on est plutôt assez
optimistes les premiers résultats
montrent on est sur des niveaux
bree bien inférieurs que ce qu'on peut
entendre quand on est long de
l'autoroute là ou bien inférieur un
aéroport ou bien inférieur à une ligne
aile ligne de train classique donc là
dessus ça devrait vous devriez être plus
tôt beaucoup plus on va dire accepter ce
type d'infrastructure de façon beaucoup
plus aisé que si c'était une autoroute
ou une nouvelle autoroute ou à
l'élargissement de la 406 gens non j'ai
une question ou par rapport à votre
propre future clientèle est ce que
l'être humain il est je parle d'un point
de vue psychologique est ce qu'il est
prêt à accepter d'être d'être dans une
machine qui roule à 1000 kilomètres
comme ça et qu'ils soient pas dans les
arts je parle pas des avions je sais
qu'il est habitué aux avions est-ce qui
est ce que ça peut poser problème chez
votre clientèle ou alors oui je pense
pas clairement y avoir une phase
d'acceptation de ce nouveau système de
transport
aujourd'hui ça on comprend référence par
exemple comment le métro est arrivé dans
nos vies il ya cent ans et on a un petit
peu ce même type de réflexion c'est à
dire qu'il ya 100 ans personne ne
voulait descendre sous terre pour
prendre le métro
et aujourd'hui voilà il va falloir c'est
pour ça qu'on fait énormément de
d'interviews et de conférence pour
expliquer le système
après d'un point de vue transport en
soit c'est pas plus différents que
l'avion on est sur des accélérations
similaire au métro on n'est pas en train
de concevoir un canon électromagnétique
donc on va pas avoir demandé aux gens de
faire des entraînements de cosmonaute
pour comprendre ce nouveau mode de
transport mais mais vraiment voilà on
est sur la même niveau même niveau
d'accélération que le métro à montréal
et ensuite le temps d'arriver à la
vitesse de croisière et après vous
l'avez dit vous-même tout à l'heure on
peut se déplacer on se déplace dans
l'avion jeu se passe bien et là c'est
exactement la même chose puisque l
aspect mais je vous laisse terminer tout
laisse terminer non un président des
voyelles aspect claustrophobie là on va
vas y et sur l'expérience client à la
limite à l'heure je voyais les résultats
sur le nombre de passagers pense que les
trois réponses sont bonnes mais avoir
dépassé les 80 passagers c'est un peu le
mode bétaillère là quand le métro est
plein de matin là c'est pas terrible
mais c'est bon pour le rhône le
rendement économique du système mais
d'un point de vue expérience client
c'est pas génial
ap indépendamment de sa voix là on peut
vraiment travailler avec des écrans il
ya aujourd'hui énormément de choses qui
se fait il que ce soit avec de la
réalité virtuelle de la réalité
augmentée avec la possibilité de
projeter des images en 360
pendant le trajet donc je pense qu'on
peut vraiment faire quelque chose de
mieux que ce qu'on a aujourd'hui dans
des trajets classique en mutilant
viarail ou même la sncf fils maintenant
qu'est ce qui arrive là j'me magic je
m'imagine g20 en tunnel sous la manche
si un problème pas d'électricité
le système arrête celle en milieu du
tube je veux bien sûr à rouler dans une
belle cabine
mais qu'est ce que je fais pour sortir
du cube alors il ya plusieurs scénarios
le scénario on va dire classique c'est
comme ceux qui sait ce qui se passe dans
le métro où la liste s'arrête vous
attendez une minute
le la ligne rodez marc normalement tout
va bien et c'est si jamais il ya un
événement majeur
l'attaqué terroriste un tremblement de
terre et c'est déjà d'une part nous on
est soumis à des normes très rigoureuses
en terme de sécurité et il y en a une
notamment qu'ils nous imposent à avoir
une sortie d'évacuation tous les 700
mètres à peu près un peu plus baissier
et derrière il faut que transporte soit
capable de démontrer que le véhicule se
déplace ou soit toi dedans à porte dans
des modes dégradé extrême d'être capable
de se positionner en face la sortie des
vacations et bien sûr en fait on a un
avantage
on va dire important par rapport à
l'avion avec le tube est au sol donc
même si on est dans un environnement à
faible pression on peut re pressurisée
le tube de façon très rapide tu apprends
15 secondes pour pressuriser le tube et
ensuite pour permettre aux passagers
d'évacuer normalement déjà d'une part
sortir du pod est ensuite sortir du cube
vous parlez de pressurisation ce que ça
veut dire que ce tube se promènerait
j'ai pas moi est ce qu'ils se promènent
sur l'air ça fonctionne comme un an fait
louis le concept juste pour revenir on
expliqué à nos auditeurs
le concept pour pouvoir atteindre 1000
km heure il faut en fait enlever les
frottements aérodynamique et pour
enlever les frottements aérodynamique
en fait on enlève 90% de l'air dans le
tube donc il ya quasiment pas d'air dans
le tube en fait pour justement enlevés
voilà tous ces frottements là et
atteindre des vitesses élevées dans tube
si on était à pression atmosphérique
bien là autant ça sert à rien d'être
dans un tube autant utiliser un train
marie-claude moi où je vois un genre de
problème possible c'est quand vous
parlez que vous voulez transporter des
humains mais aussi de la marchandise
voile alors parce que si on compare
cependant avec le métro là c'est
vraiment dédié 100 % au transport des
personnes
mais c'est quand on fait les deux puis
qu'on a on implique des grosses
compagnies qui l'a certainement avoir le
monopole de certains tubes il va falloir
se partager les tubes c'est un peu le
même genre de problème quand même avec
les trains maintenant comme les rails
qui appartiennent à ces aides
il faut qu'ils aient dépassé et ranger
et comment est ce que vous anticipez
savent ou alors ça va être je pense un
bon problème à traiter parce que si les
gens se battent c'est à dire qu'il ya un
marché que transpole est profitable
donc ça c'est une bonne nouvelle et on a
eu également donc les premiers marchés
vont sûrement être du frais de la
marchandise est par contre on n'est pas
concurrent de cni de cp quand on parle
de transport de marchandises c'est tout
ce qui est sensé
l'otan donc tout ce qui est commerce en
ligne et la nourriture
donc tout ce qui est transporté par
commerce en ligne et fret express
donc tout ce que transporte amazon tout
ce que transporte fedex dhl ups canada
fausses et tout ce que peut transporter
des sociétés comme la blouse ou pas
voilà les sociétés où wall mart
voilà qui a besoin de transporter de la
nourriture j'ai un ami qui est grossiste
prom âgées à montréal et qui envoient
des fromages régulièrement à toronto et
les t il à 30 % de pertes quand les
camions arrivent à toronto
donc il ya vraiment voilà un besoin de
transporter ce type de marchandises plus
rapidement et les retours que l'on a de
ces sociétés là c'est que demain s'il ya
un corridor entre toronto et montréal
les le tuba est à pleine capacité dès le
premier jour il ya suffisamment de
trafic pour justifier sa est donc ce
sera à transpole de comment dirais-je de
d'innover et de fournir plus de
capacités on a quelques idées on pense à
pouvoir faire par exemple ce qu'on
appelle du plateau ni goût du coup place
virtuelle donc juste pour expliquer en
fait c'est d'avoir plusieurs véhicules
qui se suffisent comme des voitures
autonomes sur une autoroute pour
justement augmenter le nombre de
véhicules est à la fois pouvoir avoir du
passager et de la marchandise monsieur
gendron on arrive en gare il faut se
dépêcher
question pouvez vous parliez de
l'expérience client transpole
je pense à ipod est ce que ça veut dire
que les gens auront accès à tous les
outils électroniques
oui bien sûr c'est clairement notre
objectif on vit dans un monde je prenais
kt et digital donc oui ça fait partie de
notre développement d'assurer un niveau
de connexion élevé dans chaque véhicule
pour que les gens puissent travailler
monsieur gendron fantastique merci de
nous avoir parlé du de votre transport
et on va s'assurer de donner à nos
téléspectateurs le moyen de poursuivre
leur découverte de vaud dans votre
initiative en ce moment merci laurence
grâce justement aux web merci puis à
bientôt
bonne chance au revoir merci sébastien
gendron cofondateur et pdg de transpole
premier défi l'ancienne région
depuis il n'était pas au courant et
voici ils vont nous amener sur le site
de transport qui je le donne comme ça en
lettres en bon comme dans le bon vieux
temps www.sa lors transport.com
transport.com un camp slash fr pour ceux
qui veulent ça en français ok et puis
slash
sinon c'est vraiment révolutionnaire
moi j'avais des frissons c'est vraiment
vous avez pas entendu pas remettre ça
mais se taisent vaguement mais je sais
pas que c'est aussi proche de calais
avec de l'argent qui a été mise
oui ça se parle c'est sûr alors ça c'est
le site de transport là c'est la version
française donc des images qu'on n'avait
pas encore vu comme je vous dis ils ont
des belles images belles présentations
ils sont pas les seuls il y avait sept
compères se voit que c'est français
parce que c'est le titre il en anglais
c'est un coup ce qui est excitant un
anglais il parle beaucoup il perd loupe
ah oui d'accord écoutez on est prêt pour
le deuxième jeu wii qui a perdu déboule
au premier jeu le mélanome a response il
ya seulement marie club carioca
sauf que oui oui viendront a dit que les
trois ont trois possibilités pouvait
être utilisé oui mais là on vous parlait
de l'accompagner https d'accompagner
fois sa compagne l huile à sa campagne à
lui il est hors concours évidemment
alors voici sa mère trouve la perdre
on voit si https l'autre compagnie la la
plus grosse les gosses dit avoir inventé
un nouveau matériau ou matériels
composés pour recouvrir sa capsule de
passagers qui serait résistant et
intelligent et qui a des propriétés
particulières comment se nomme ce
matériel matériaux sains et que fait-il
exactement voici le choix il s'agit du
neptune yonne qui permet de garder la
capsule en lévitation
il s'agit du livrable du vibranium qui
permet de réduire des consommations à
bord ont fait un gros problème
bénévolat ou encore est ce que c'est le
sait le pro tak signe homme qui permet
de réduire la poussière au frère cadet
de hockey les projets minutes signés ou
c'est un élément naturel donc ça et
qu'est ce que vous avez dit le corps de
notre vignoble
ça existe ça existe pour vrai with dans
le tableau de chimie va je suis génial
j'ai inventé cinq ans donc c'est pas la
bonne réponse est oui alors c'est pas la
bonne réponse c'est un véritable élément
qui existait déjà
la compagnie n'a pas inventé une chose
de plus c'est le sel vibranium il a un
peu bizarre netanya mise ne ligne homme
avait quelque chose dont un combo sud ou
du possible pour nous c'est le sait ben
moi aussi alors on se trompe rarement
non je veux dire ah bah vous et si on
vous dit que c'est pas la bonne
cb d'abord b vous gardez vos boules
[Musique]
alors bravo ça n'existait pas il salue
les vibrations et c'est intelligent ça
permet de détecter quand la capsule
allemand elle vivote roues et les
risques de m'éclater pour que la lèvre
est à venir est allé chercher ça ou
c'est un véritable élément a depuis eu
de même que le neptunium coffre il je
suis dans la liste des éléments parce
que je ne connais pas tous évidemment je
suis pas je fais des études en sciences
mais quand même pourquoi pas longtemps
très longtemps je te prête alors
prochaine question
deuxième défi de la rive de la régie
êtes vous prêts oui il faut les faire
travailler un peu parce qu'ils font rien
pendant qu'on nous en parle c'est grâce
à eux qu'on est là voici le deuxième
défi de la rigide on va aller sur le
site web de de travail
voilà c'est ce qui pourra aller plus
loin dans vos réflexions vos découvertes
marie-claude vous qui ne connaissait pas
cette affaire là tant que c'était aussi
des articles on a déjà publié sur ça et
pas mal oui oui oui c'est en 2018 tu
m'as déjà
c'est vous qui aviez fait ça non un de
mes articles
un article n'est pas de moi on a ajouté
un autre article également voilà
l'article sur la vitesse l'autoroute 401
on parlait de l'autre les limites de
vitesse en ontario il faut augmenter sa
en vue de la compétition qui s'annonce
donc trans pas de ce qu'on pourrait
augmenter à 1000 kilomètres heure mais
le voyage par auto sinon c'est 110
km/heure et plus
voilà c'est intéressant pour les gens
les tekken rouler plus vite ce genre
j'ai remarqué qu'ils roulent plus vite
un peu pas mal beaucoup surtout à l
approche de la saint jean
ce matin je suis dépassée par une
motocyclette qui devait rouler à 188 km
zoom comme ça en plein centre coeur de
montréal zoom alors play trafic à
travers les eaux glacées ce point de nos
petites annonces à ce sujet par tuer
puis ça tu vas directement par en prison
parce qu'on fait pas ça au québec et la
personne s'en aller ou à la danse est
buteur de centre-ville et se dépêcher
pour partir en vacances
elle travaille à radio canada
international alors nous avons montré
que ce qui vous atteint suis allé comme
ça on voulait en savoir plus grâce à
radio canada fait longtemps que ça joue
cette boule goûtez moi j'ai envie de
vous faire découvrir le passé qui
semblait très futuriste ya pas si
longtemps ça s'appelle le turbo train je
vais vous montrer pendant que je vous
décris ça des images du turbo train en
aidant les années où au début des années
60 jusqu'aux 1976 il ya c'était on a en
anglais c'était de tout reproche en
outre à 12 banques françaises turbo et
via rail
on a eu une version entre man et toronto
imaginé la vitesse à l'époque du tweet
années 1960 à 1966 1967 il y avait il y
avait des passages du livre est passé de
400 km
puis 160 170 ha oui mais jusqu'à 265 m
autour des lans jamais fait souvent un
petit bout de décès aux états unis avec
leurs passagers
le problème c'est les rats il devra
patiner six ans ne sont pas tout le
temps ouais ce qui m'amène à ma
troisième et dernière question
marie-claude à garder et serez toujours
toutefois il prend goût
oui vous avez tout c'est pas parce que
je brille dans ce domaine même 50 boules
à perdre
d'accord bah c'est ce qu'il me reste
alors moi je souhaite vous faire votre
éducation où ça marche ça marche
toujours présent dans les cages quelques
des studios 0 moi j'en apprends beaucoup
de tout ce que je vous apporte c'est des
choses que j'ai appris des choses que
vous savez on départ sur soumah niveau
vous voici quelques grandes innovations
techniques se trouvait dans le turbo
train jamais vu jusque alors une
première au monde
est ce que le turbo frein le turbo train
pouvait s'incline dans les courbes
est ce que le turbo empreinte pouvait
passer d'une suspension pendulaires ou
est-ce que le turbo train possédait un
atténuateur de forces centrifuges
allongé pour le segment gérer pour le
sosie sait pas encore mais le a fait
c'est clean mais je vais aller pour les
bébés le p bon alors j'ai dû abaisser
aujourd'hui et vous êtes tous gagnants
parce qu'on décrit le même phénomène
il a fait ça c'est le travail effectué
un mouvement tendue dans les courbes
cassin et émulateurs de forces
centrifuges et souv est donc belle
suspension merci stéphane thépaut tous
50 boulot oui enfin pour ça voilà je
suis méchant gentil vibrations libre à
les brader libre et n'ira plus
intelligent maintenant vous allez faire
appel à vos connaissances générales
celle qu'ils avaient requis durant la
semaine
au fait qu'est ce qu'on veut en photo
daphné en décalé si j'en fais quoi les
commandes on nomme jeux en 2018 la photo
de l'image la semaine à dakar dans
l'actualité que c'est sûr c'est toujours
dans l'actualité au canada et puis je
réponds juste part ou par non est-ce que
c'est au canada oui qu'est-ce que c'est
un animal c'est une drôle de bête mais
ce n'est pas aussi motif il va pas aimer
ça continue
ce que ça oui
est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qui travaille
à radio canada international se pointait
ce we à six leur série qui regarde si
l'image qu'on ait dit oui à cette
surprise qui rigolent de l'autre chef
personnes invitées de la diversité au
départ mosaïque marionnettes et musique
voilà
médias - music.com une agence de presse
puis c'est un divin donc se tenir
et puis il a accordé une entrevue la
jument différentes images parce que quel
gars sympathique d'abord et puis surtout
quelqu'un ça c'est pas lui
mais quelqu'un qui lui ressemble non
mais la même source ovalie non là oui
c'est un thread la photo c'est un
dramaturge algérie ci devraient attester
tués pendant la décennie noire à des
caméras nous là sur le web non
d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs notre rédacteur en chef a
assisté à un événement sur lui je pense
c'est pour ça qu'il a eue le lien
ouais ça l'est pour toujours la
moustache il souligné parce qu'à une
époque c'était très à la mode
moi mon père en avait une et l'a gardé
toute sa vie et souvent apprennent
sectionné plus non je ne sais pas ça
mais maintenant c'est la barbe et la
moustache mais ça devrait les garder la
manche barbie château si oui alors je
sais ça lui fait plaisir
un gars comme ça n'aurait jamais accepté
que qu'on lui dit on va parler de toi
aujourd'hui nous mêmes ne serait pas
nécessaire je limite bien et puis
revenant je voulais quand même me faire
plaisir je pense que vous devez lui
faire plaisir si le patron après tout et
je vais parler de l'application chers
téléspectateurs
et internautes qui nous écoutait à
travers le monde alors encore une fois
je vous encourage nous vous encourageons
à télécharger sur votre téléphone
notre application que vous pouvez
trouver en cinq langues donc en français
anglais chinois arabe et espagnol si
vous avez un iphone vous allez sur a été
ou non ce que je m'épanouisse appel et
puis ici alors voilà on la voit un peu à
vous allez même des vidéos sans notre
c'est très bien présente même un quiz
ouais ouais on peut la voir sur
tablettes aussi parce que sur téléphone
vous l'avez vous sur tablette sami ouais
tout à fait déjà ça va à peu près ça
fait un bon bout comme ben oui voilà et
voilà alors ça c'est magnifique
et moi je vais en cinq langues ici
personne ne peut changer le vent on
avait les chefs nous indique allez pas
me chefs qui ont sorti que ça
fonctionnait très très fort surtout du
côté français la les milliers de gens
qui se connectaient qui avaient
téléchargé là j'ai pas les plus récentes
nouvelles le patron n'en voit qu'une
mouche à savoir ce qui se passe c'est
moi faire enfin vérification si le
patron et oui peut-être que vous envoyez
un mémo demandons des new wave ou le
faire soit vous même vous avez
autorisation c'est pas et que tu es en
donc merci à tout le monde d'avoir
participé aujourd'hui
bon retour merci beaucoup et puis sa
mère ce jour ces actes acculèrent du
vous à voir avec un merci c'est partager
même quand vous n'avez pas de boules l'a
pratiquement à la fin d'une émission de
vibranium ou le monde et va trouver ça
on va s'en souvenir
alors ici stéphane fera la semaine
prochaine
et puis non moi non la semaine prochaine
cheval h
je suis en train de construire quelque
chose c'est pas de supertubes l' on se
rends toi mais tu as une dune j'ai érigé
une barrière pour empêcher le passage du
transport que ça se passe à la campagne
on affaires générales alors dans deux
semaines je vous retrouve et puis merci
beaucoup à tout le monde
[Musique]